torna il libro si parla di fort knight
two player con console grazie a dio
seconda parte l'ex ma write
abbiamo qua un maestro che spieghi è un
quadro è un quadro si fa vedere
praticamente la crescita di un essere
umano prima e la morte la morte se vuoi
un bambino è nato tutto premuri prima
brunetta lo andiamo a morire provo a
caso vediamo bene sto già jap fare
questo è complicato e poi quello dopo di
saltare qua poi dato a farlo occhio che
qua ci sono delle trappole tra l'altro
apriamo l'ombrellino ragazzi a primo
librerie che teoricamente teoricamente è
però guarda che secondo me ci deve fare
così nel senso che secondo me se
volevano togliere l'ombrellino lo
toglievano a prescindere quindi non
eccita con la pensata come allora allora
è praticamente il tuo primo momento su
fornet detto ok è proprio un momento
importantissimo come il primo passo è
stata troppo la prima parola che viene
il primo veti di trappola non si scorda
mai
ok quindi la pavimentazione sarà voglio
morire
ok esatto fa per dire la sua prima
parola voglio morire
ok è bravissimo ragazzo bravissimo
avevo anche la soundboard pronta ok
brava la alla fine servizio
ok e l'inizio di quella band not bad dai
perfetto come prima è andato benissimo
vedi perché abbiamo l'ombrellino sì
perché adesso dobbiamo prima e schivare
le trappole credo a roba del genere
giusto
vabbè si pensa pesa la crisi se non che
mi lamenti è però però vabbè bravi
ragazzi complimenti siamo espertissimi
stiamo andando super spedita effetto
normale abbiamo iniziato benissimo
pensavo fossero molto più difficile agli
altri ma ho parlato
saranno un casino scusate cosa dobbiamo
fare
devi arrivare prima la sopra destra
sicuro c'è una trappola sinistra però
noi non ci arriviamo a destra
ok ragazzi è posto a 6 che anche secondo
no no no non scusami coperto puoi fare
no non forse sono collegati aspetta da
questo quali vi è quello sopra può
essere può essere aspetto può essere sì
si sono collegate insomma è quello sopra
perfetto tra mario in alto possibile vai
vai sta il figliolo ok non ci sembra una
nave senza semplice beh ps mi sono
sorpreso per non rovinare tutto bravi ma
che partenza fantastico raga questo solo
voglio fare la spiega appropriamo aia
papa si muore perfetto dei byte aree
prima la trappola puoi andare no
scherzavo proprio nella di aver capito
che non vara
non è vero quasi vero c'ero quasi cielo
quasi raga dai dai dai fattibile è
fattibile ci credo bravo come fatto ok
non puoi farlo anche dall'esterno
stavo scherzando ragazzi io ho fatto
tipo il secondo salvatore bravo non ci
credo spazio contare il fashion e caduto
ed è fatta conoscere fatta ce l'ho fatta
adesso atterrare su l'affare li tiri
esatto
ok ti conviene poi stare nella parte blu
e lei farà di tutto perché non ho
qualsiasi tipo un po più soli come fai a
stare lì è impossibile tel avrai non son
difficili come difficili sembrano molto
più difficile a vedersi ok vediamo se
c'hai ragione dai ci hai ragione ma li
piano piano se lo fai tranquilla ok ma
dal blu el'altro blu devo andare a t ma
è così perché è più comodo molto bene
perfetto c'è il fight subito paura
questa ecco questo era molto difficile
rispetto agli iniziali si allora qua
credo che siamo gli ex ds benissimo ok
deviando i ribelli indietro indietro di
premere indietro adesso
una brutta notizia che bello perché
finora era tutto bello noi da qua
dobbiamo riuscire a saltare gli alla
destra quindi un salto curvo lungo
wow se tipo il peggio ciao io sono come
ok e da qua qua ra qua
devi fare la stessa cosa mi sa ragazzi
davvero si fa la stessa cosa solo che
non vedo cosa c'è dopo quindi un casino
buono che buono mamma mia
no non sto facendo lo sto facendo tutto
e di dopo è veramente ragazzi un infetto
orribile dove mauro cose fatte come
fatto come era veramente impulsi come
hai fatto fuori quella roba lì in casinò
allora spiega mi quando prendi la spi il
ghiaccio e speed salti all'ultimissima
della rampa e aprile il tap l'anno con i
suoi casinò e mezzo di arrivi dove sono
io voglio veramente morire hawkins e
l'ho fatta ma con me ma ragazzina com'è
possibile era impossibile timer di tre
ore nel senso che sono fischi interiori
sono sono pazzo nel senso che deve
iniziare dalla mappa come sono quelle
cose che non vuoi sapere per non avere a
non le volevo sapere se ti prego non si
è già fatta ecco arrivato tipo missile
va bene e stato molto difficile molto
bello però next ore 17 ma queste per
risalire se cadiamo però come fa lo
sappiamo e salta qua qua c'è un coso
sicuro ai paletti
ok ok ok ok tutto chiaro il portello che
guido io qualche non è non è il massimo
seguito io la sala stato grafica non
volevo fermo perso lo ferma dentro un po
indietro
ok basta così adesso e scendi
ok saremo felici me più cari esatto
esatto da easy pay parte l'ennesia
adesso e penso però che cavolo lo
chiedesse molto peggio sì non voglio
saltare di continuo si cosi
beh dai anzi dai no non è così
impossibile
ok per i good tutto giusto
proprio lui ancora lui no giocherà
takeshi's castro ragazzi e ci riesce
vi aspetto adesso chi è alla fine che
guarda gli altri è che facciate in
gradassi prima voce mente salti lunghi
immaginò non all'ultimo eppure pensa
quando si è l'ultimo assalto lungomare
vista al tar e alla fine perché se non
sbatte la testa
ok quindi è assurdo vi è un po un
problema proviamoci veramente difficile
no ci avevo fatto solo all'inizio
niente di certo potrebbe essere un
livello in cui rimaniamo fermi questo è
il 18 ok dai e ora dal t un po in
ritardo e poi niente ti piace sbattere
la testa per sa che siamo feretro ottimo
di citarlo brutalmente anni lo so se
funziona si evita evitare il muro
proprio andare a 30 destra qui però non
non ci sono arrivata fini dallo stesso
punziano e provati no arrivi non si
arrivi ci provo per curiosità è che gli
faceva l'ombrellino dai sono o sono
giustificato per questo solo questo ci è
difficilissimo dai passate ce l'ha non
voglio più vedere che ci aspettiamo 18
vai nonché il liceo dove sembra meglio
però ti lascio la nave
grazie non ho capito esatto abitanti
giochi tipo bambino quando devi correre
ma si scivola credo sia un po lo stesso
pensano che adesso vi faccio anche il
tempismo
ciao ok ho capito capito non quello di
fitch fai tutto tutto tutto tutto tutto
tutto tutto
bravo e vabbè ma impossibile aspetti
forse a vedervi in corso all'inizio può
essere seri e se la prende più in corso
all'inizio perché anche capi tanto l'ho
capito la tattica non aspettiamo a sogni
imbecille io non sono un imbecille 86
fermo lì perché se ne ho vinti alla
veglia all'altro perché provato ornate
da tempo ok ma è finita io devo il mio
sei morto allora combinato allora non
come terrore sono successe delle cose di
saltare sul ghiaccio e saltare subito
per andare lì avanti ma subito
sull'avanti oppure sull'altro ghiaccio
anche sul ghiaccio e poi subito in
avanti si aspetti di blocchi dov'ero io
in avanti all isola dei famosi a fare
ancora il 18 siamo alberi se rimarrò
sempre dai allora guardate una roba lo
vedete che c'è la scritta uscita si
potrebbe ovviare al 20 ma chiede il
finale oppure ci vuole parlare
vabbè ma stranamente la pina e vi
assicuro che non è per niente semplice
cosa sono cose strane sapere dove va
bene ok
questo è un problema che va bene ragazzi
allora io lascerei i due poverini in
questo caso ci riprovano e cinque eroi e
vediamo cosa c'è dietro la porta a
league proprio anche per noi va bene
ciao ragazzi vediamo santo altri livelli
magari abbiamo finito il mio marito
yacht c'è un corridoio molto lungo
attenzione c'è un'altra porta c'è una
scala che porta fuori e ragazzi
attenzione potrebbe essere finito
signori credo sia finito
credo sia fi come si fa a capire se è
finito niente ragazzi ringrazio i flyers
one console per senti come come briga
bel aprile grazie alle partecipate per
ogni insegnato come fare parkour c
arrivato alla fine solo io e te ne devi
guardare lo ricordiamo non si sa mai
e queste non ricadiamo che mi sia
piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale youtube
players che lascia in descrizione come
se vi è piaciuto è stato molto in piace
iscriviti al canale e non ci vediamo da
ragazzi ciao
[Musica]